freunde herz gekommen zu diesem video
ist ein traumhafter tag ich bin weder
negativ noch ein strich wird aber
wollten bin ich wieder frei und kann
dementsprechend auch weil wieder andere
videos als die bestell videos von mir zu
hause dreht die idee vom heutigen video
kam von einem von euch und zwar werde
ich heute die am wenigsten bestellten
menüpunkt bei restaurants bestellt das
hatte ganz bestimmten hintergrund weil
dadurch findet man entweder nicht so
gute sachen oder aber vielleicht so ein
paar versteckte diamanten sohin james
die einfach gut schmecken die aber
vielleicht ein bisschen abschreckend
sind wir wissen zu exotisch sind und
genau das finden wir heute heraus lohnt
es sich genau diese sachen zu bestellen
wir machen es jetzt friedrich schiller
kennt ihr vielleicht hatte ich schon mal
ein video allerdings haben wir ziemliche
vielfalt ihr seht ihr jetzt hier schon
mal eine kleine übersicht gibt wirklich
viele viele verschiedene bürger jetzt
auch mal fragen welcher der ist der am
wenigsten bestellt wird und ich stellen
ich wünsche ich kenne von einigen werden
hey ihr max kurze frage ich drehe ein
youtube video und möchte gerne den
artikel bestellt ihr bei euch am
wenigsten bestellt wird
also würden bürger seien möglicherweise
also gleich noch eine beilage dann dazu
ok also big kahuna christina dann vielen
dank und ich verstehe jetzt dankeschön
[Applaus]
ok haut also kritisch kennen im
bürgerladen ja ich habe da schon plate
ich habe glaub ich auch damals im video
gesagt das ist ja sehr gerne stelle
deshalb diesen an us-bürger ab juni
bestellt weil ich anders auch mal pizza
ist ja schon so ein streitthema aber
anders auf einem burger kann das
wirklich geil wenn ich bin selbst
spannen und diese christina jetzt ich
hab ich noch nie bestellen können und
unsere zweite andere verleiht von usecon
wir werden dort jetzt ein mal gucken was
es überhaupt gibt also vorspeisen
relativ klassische springers
frühlingsrolle ganz offensichtlich nicht
sein aber crash majerus das relativ
wenig zu dem was ich hatte vor zwei
videos deshalb hoffe ich dass ihr auch
relativ gut bestellt werden ein
reichsgericht hauptgerichte nudelsuppen
nachtisch ist ganz normal
hallo hier merkst kurze frage ich würde
gerne die speise bestellen die wir euch
am wenigsten bestellt welche ist das
genau die nicht so gut läuft so einfach
aus dem bauchgefühl heraus muss nicht
genau die seien sondern einfach eine wo
man sagt okay wir stellen nicht so viele
kunden
[Applaus]
kaufen skeptisch äußerten und irgend ein
hauptgericht dazu
wichtig dass stelle das ganze für ein
youtube-video also ich gut weil es
trocken und was ich das was am wenigsten
bestellt wird das interesse um
herauszufinden ob die sachen zu unrecht
so wenig gestellt werden genau
ok cool fischverkäufer herzlichen
dankeschön schott es war eine schwere
geburt müssen wir uns bei einigen das
tor aus anrufen bis wir es geschafft
haben aber recht fisch reis und fisch
von curry topf kann ich mir überhaupt
nichts drunter vorstellen ich bin
gespannt was ankommen wird die zweite
bestellung ist als erstes angekommen
fisch von curry topf fresh fish des dib
dazu und reizt es gibt super nice aus
den dich also hier schönes frisches
gemüse bei diesem crash die frau zwei
kinder was sie erwarten das ist auch so
fresh fish frischer fisch also roher
fisch
[Musik]
kannst du eigentlich auch nicht so gut
vorstellen der fische drin ist das bad
oder eigentlich kommt dazu so ein talent
und wir haben es irgendwie so ein msi
bekommt mehr fahrbereit und
fresh fish ist das ja jetzt eine
überraschung ich bin gespannt
wie das ganze damit dass auch mal ein
bisschen soße aufnehmen kann gehe ich
jetzt noch mal rein
also direkt erstes feedback precious ist
wirklich also es schmeckt frisch so
würde ich nochmal bestellt
wahrscheinlich nicht einfach weil macht
irgendwie nicht so krass gut außer
gesund zu sein also man kann es auf
jeden fall trotzdem essen wird niemals
andere vorspeise dafür eintauschen würde
dem wahrscheinlich seine sechs von zehn
geben auch hier haben wir wieder dass
viele hier haben wir auch also stolze
stücke combat quasi gut durchgegart ich
probiere direkt man
hier gefällt er mir direkt schon viel
besser also ich kann erst mal verstehen
dass weniger leute fisch bestellen weil
fisch ist immer so ein kleines risiko
man das immer so ein kleines mulmiges
gefühl und bestellt eigentlich nur ein
letzter romantiker ist alles super froh
wenn die größte gefahr für sowas wie
leben kinder versorgt dieser basis aber
es besucherdienst die soße aus dem
kunden schmeckt auch wirklich sehr die
currysauce ist auch mein geschmack er
für mich ein absolutes sommergericht es
ist aber trotzdem muss ich auch sagen
keine krasse erleuchtung für mich ist
jetzt nicht so als würde ich sagen auch
hier würde ich wahrscheinlich rechts
anderen bevorzugen also ich hatte da
helfen nicht die krasse überraschung
finde es aber sehr sehr gut himmel
schöne solides linien half uns hingegen
glaube ich und unsere zweite bestellung
ist da muss ehrlich sagen darauf bin ich
ganz besonders gespannt wir haben hier
unseren big kahuna ananas burger und
hier haben wir unsere crispy chicken
bahrain
crispy scheint kein understatement zu
sein also das sind erstmal durch jede
menge zehn stück sind dass das sind
unsere saucen dazu ist ohne scharfe soße
dazu bestellt einfach kurzer prozess
christina jetzt in die scharfe soße und
also ich schlafe so ist es wirklich
schafft findet meinem mund brennt ja
gehört christi ist kein understatement
jetzt gehörte sind wirklich cool spd
heißt nicht nur so und das obwohl auf
dem trip von dem lärm der formung
anderen personen abgearbeitet und sophie
sind durch ganz köln erst mal gefahren
sind immer noch kurz bringt das ist
krass wenn man aber mal genau schaut
sieht man dass die ein bisschen trocken
sind wir sind leider nicht so super sagt
sich im dritten mal in einem stück noch
mal ein anderes
hinter der kamera zum einbau auf
spielzeug kaufen um jedoch bereit
gestellt hast richtig schwer
alle stände noch mal ein stück also du
weißt etwas rx unsere männer leiden das
bisschen weniger kommen das ist jetzt
auch nicht schlecht ab konzern aus dem
bauch heraus weil pro tag knusprig
könnte da sein aber das produkt an sich
ist geil weil es halt nicht so stark
wird dass so wenig bestellt also ich
sehe ich kann es nur damit beantworten
ich habe das auch nie gesehen entweder
es relativ neu oder die leute bestellen
nicht als beilage zum burger nuggets was
auch sinn machen würde ich sagen ehrlich
sehr leid werde ich wieder bestellen
weil ich könnte mir vorstellen dass sie
auch sagte ja noch ankommen könnten das
schlechten tag erwischt hat und dass
hier so was ist der eigentliche grund
weshalb ich das video hier drehe einen
anderen schauen wir uns gemeinsam an der
big kahuna ich wäre wirklich abseits
dieses videos glaube ich nicht auf die
idee gekommen ihn zu bestellen er sieht
niemand vertreten ihn kennt wirklich
sehr hübsch aus also wir haben hier
selbst gemacht und waren zu wir haben
süß saurer soße sehe ich das richtig
dass von der sweet chili genau rote
zwiebeln in schweineschmalz von teese
richtiges partie und sah das ist
interessante angelegenheit auf jeden
fall und das gericht hat daran es ist
durchaus möglich also kann ich nicht so
richtig beschreiben wir können jetzt
einfach ein bisschen und wir gucken ob
das funktioniert anders auf dem burger
los geht's
das krasse ist es ist eine suite die
soße und das macht das schlägt die
brücke und man weiß woran man kriegen
ersten süßen von dieser sweet chili soße
dann knüpft daran die etwas weniger
süßes annagasse aber es ist gar nicht
eigenartig also nie im leben wirklich
hätte ich gedacht dass das so schmecken
würde irgendwie habe ich das gefühl
dieser völker sollte nicht existieren
aber trotzdem macht er vieles richtig es
ist jetzt durch die süße die so komisch
und so anders ist auch einen burger das
wirst du bisher 100 bürger in einem
essen aber trotzdem ist irgendwie geil
was auch nicht wie ihr seht es hier
richtig ist so eine eingelegte ananas
für das gesamte partie über den gesamten
bürger verteilt und es ist dadurch fast
ganz ganz anderes also ich versteh 100%
warum das nicht so häufig bestellt wird
das ding ist der ist perfekt ausgeführt
so der ist anders als die crispy chicken
länger so da kann man was für mängeln
wird aber der ist eigentlich perfekt so
deshalb überlegt zwischen 7 und 8 ich
würde ihnen an einem tag im jahr
vielleicht auch im sommer weil es
irgendwie auch sommer nicht merkwürdig
ihnen wieder bestellen und ich finde ihn
auch lecker schweren deckel drauf zu
packen weil damit habe ich wirklich
nicht gerechnet dass er so schmeckt dass
das so ist nichtsdestotrotz jungen mann
habe ich jetzt auch mal eine mysteriöse
art und weise in essen zu bestellen
durch irgendwann beim einfach so im
handstand sind oder wie auch immer aber
danke dass ihr mit mir die
quarantänezeit überstanden habe die
lassen wir weiter schmecken und jetzt
geht es wieder richtig gut
[Musik]